to setha the future was a matter of
keeping the past at bay
the better life she believed she and
denver were living was simply not that
other one
beloved is the magnum opus of the late
great toni morrison it has become a key
piece of literature taught in schools
well
that's another story never mind and
considered one of the great pieces of
american literature also it is serving
horror realness
to understand beloved we must first look
at the woman behind the pages nobel
prize winner tony morrison
[Music]
tony morrison is one of those writers
who has transcended her work to become
an icon in and of herself
her hometown lorraine ohio even has a
tony morrison day on her birthday
february 18th aquarius born in 1931 as
chloe ardella wofford the girl who would
become tony morrison was an avid reader
soaking up her favorite authors like leo
tolstoy and jane austen me too and other
expressions of storytelling everything
from singing to ghost stories to
african-american folk tales while her
parents encouraged this kind of
expression and exposure to all manner of
stories it maybe should have been a
tip-off that there was something
uniquely special about this child i mean
tolstoy jane austen
she's a thinker after studying english
at howard university and then earning
her ma in english at cornell morrison
taught english classes of her own at
texas southern university and howard
soon she pivoted to editing becoming the
first black woman senior editor at
random house's fiction department
this would mark only one important first
in a long long line of firsts that tony
morrison would become
in 1970 morrison finally published a
novel of her own the bluest eye and
continued building steam with honors
like the 1977
national book critic circle award for
her third novel song of solomon and her
induction into the ohio women's hall of
fame in 1982 but it was in 1987 she
published her fifth novel beloved which
would cement tony morrison as a truly
iconic american writer beloved was a
game changer it not only garnered
morrison the pulitzer prize for fiction
and paved the way for her to become the
first black american to win the nobel
peace prize for literature in 1993 but
it has also become a novel that is all
at once popular influential and hotly
controversial which is why it can be on
the bbc news list of 100 most
influential novels while also regularly
appearing on the american library
association's top 10 most challenged
books the reason for beloved being so
controversial well it all brings us back
to the horrors of the past including
unflinching depictions of violence
infanticide and slave
in a postmodern move that would make
even virginia wolf blush one could argue
that those wishing to ban the novel may
be committing the same offense as
beloved's protagonists refusing to
confront the past in hopes that doing so
will make it go away
our story is set in cincinnati ohio in
1873 shortly after the civil war
technically the war is over technically
the enslaved are free juneteenth has
happened but that doesn't change the
entrenched beliefs and behavior of a
country overnight so setha finds herself
in a sort of purgatorial existence
technically free
but not truly psychologically
spiritually free
toni morrison writes
every day was a test and a trial nothing
could be counted on in a world where
even when you were a solution
you were a problem
even worse what small semblance of
freedom and autonomy she has as a mother
and caretaker for her family is slipping
from her grasp
her mother-in-law baby suggs has long
since passed away her husband went
missing years ago her two young sons
howard and bulger ran off her other baby
daughter beloved is dead but not gone
so by 1873 that just leaves seth and her
18 year old daughter denver to fend for
themselves at 124 bluestone road and the
ghosts have set this baby girl all the
while haunting them for seth's past sins
morrison rise of the house on bluestone
road
124 was spiteful
full of a baby's venom
the women in the house knew it and so
did the children
when paul d one of the formerly enslaved
men from seth's former plantation sweet
home arrives he forces the ghost out but
then the ghost reforms into the body of
a young woman who calls herself beloved
beloved begins to torment paul d pushing
him out of the house and forcing him to
revisit horrible moments from his past
using sexual violence setha eventually
confesses to paul dee that she tried to
kill her children in order to not have
them return to slavery but managed only
to kill her baby daughter beloved was
the only name she could afford to put on
the gravestone
thinking that beloved's return signals
her family coming back together setha
begins to give all she is to beloved
until beloved grows bigger and setha
begins to wither away denver reaches out
to the community of village women to be
rid of beloved to exercise her bring
their family back into the community
denver is able to form a new path for
herself now as satha finally mourns
truly for the child she lost
toni morrison explains how she saw
beloveds functioning in the novel as
follows
she is a spirit on one hand literally
she is what setha thinks she is her
child returned to her from the dead
she is also another kind of dead which
is not spiritual but flesh which is a
survivor from a true factual slave ship
she speaks the language a traumatized
language of her own experience which
blends beautifully in her questions and
answers her preoccupations with the
desires of denver and sethe
the gap between africa and afro-america
and the gap between the living and the
dead and the gap between the past and
the present does not exist
it's bridged for us
by our assuming responsibility for
people no one's ever assumed
responsibility for they are those that
died in root nobody knows their names
and nobody thinks about them
there is a necessity for remembering the
horror but of course there's a necessity
for remembering it in a manner in which
it can be digested
in a manner in which the memory is not
destructive
but lover's return in the novel is about
bringing that past to the surface
because it must be faced it cannot be
stuffed in a box or forgotten
for morrison horror and truth are
synonymous
that horror is also in the realization
that seth killed her daughter in an
attempt to save her from being
recaptured into slavery
a moment inspired by the real life case
of margaret garner
garner was an enslaved woman who was
attempting to escape slavery with her
family while pregnant mind you garner
was captured in ohio under the
jurisdiction of the fugitive slave act
where it was discovered that she had
killed her two-year-old daughter rather
than have the girl be sent back into
slavery she was preparing to kill her
other children and herself when she was
stopped by a slave catcher posse when
margaret was brought to trial the
question was if she would be tried as a
person
or as property
lucy stone a prominent activist at the
time took the stand during the case and
said the fated faces of the negro
children tell too plainly to what
degradation the female slaves submit
rather than give her daughter to that
life she killed it
if in her deep maternal love she felt
the impulse to send her child back to
god to save it from coming woe
who shall say she had no right not to do
so
margaret was sent back to slavery and
would eventually die within the
institution with seth morrison gives the
historical figure space to mourn
in the freedom she made sacrifices for
barbara t christian professor of african
american studies at the university of
california berkeley
said of the importance of the work
beloved interrogates our assumptions
about literary narrative
in the bourgeois western tradition it
raises questions about the intersections
of our orthodox notions of freedom and
limits of individual agency and society
of ownership and excess presence and
absence
the past and the present the living and
the dead we can all relate to wanting to
put the past behind us
something we did or something done to us
something that made us feel ashamed or
guilty or afraid or sad
and beloved is a novel that confronts
these feelings to an extreme that stands
on the very foundation of american
history if ghost stories force us to
relive those dark times of our past
beloved functions as not only the story
of seth's pain and tragedy coming to a
head but as commentary on how the past
cannot be escaped like any good ghost
story beloved asks us to reckon with
this past to confront it and hopefully
to grow from it
we need some kind of tomorrow
before you go we here at it's lit are
launching a podcast hosted by the
amazing princess weeks that's me
it's lit under bridge features all your
favorite literature topics and
thoughtful funny conversations from
amazing authors it's basically like
joining the best book club ever but
without actually having to read anything
check out the islit podcast in the link
in the description below
you